my name is michael stipe
i'm a graphql technical steering
committee member and i'm the author of
the hot chocolate graphical library and
dot net
and today we are going to explore how we
can get started with graphql and why
graphql is awesome
before we get started let's do a quick
temperature of the room
you can
scan this
barcode
or qr code
and then we do a quick quiz
awesome
okay let's start
so who has used graphql before
or who has just heard about it or
experimented with it has it in
production
i will unlock
yeah
50 users can go on
awesome that's good because we are
getting started
so
okay let's
see the next one
ah
no i took it away
damn it
mini mistake
okay
most people think it's five years and
that is when i go to conferences
most people will exactly say it's five
years old
at dot net conferences
okay
actually it was released in 2012
and initially they called it super graph
for a lack of a better name
so in march 2012
facebook released graphql into
production
but it was only later open sourced so
graphql was open source in 2016. they
announced
that they will open source it in 2015.
that's why most people think it's
younger than it is
so graphical is quite mature at this
moment in time
but let's explore what graphql really is
or why graphql was even
created
so back in 2011
facebook faced a
big crisis with their mobile application
the mobile application actually didn't
look so sleek like this
and more looked like
this
and
users hated it
because when they started it
it was really slow sluggish
usage of it
and it used a ton of data and back then
data was precious think about how much
data capacity you had in your mobile
phones
around 2012 2011 maybe half a gigabyte
maybe a gigabyte depends on your mobile
provider today we have unlimited
on many cases we have unlimited
use of data in our mobile phones
on top of it they found out that
it really had a bad impact on your
battery your device would get hot
and it would use
in a short amount of time all your
battery
so the facebook engineers
went
and analyzed what went wrong with the
mobile application of facebook
and what they found out
is
that they done everything like they did
with their web application like with the
with the facebook web application so
they used html
they used rest as a backend
so everything seems to be fine
but when they looked at startup times
and what the application actually did
they found out it first
just fetched the user
and when they fetched the user from the
rest endpoint
it would give them some data the data
that the developers of that endpoint
actually intended for the desktop web
application
so it sent down not three properties but
around 100
properties just for the user
but that was not it because
facebook is nothing without its news
feed
so it first fetched
the user information and then just went
on to fetch the news of this user
and again not intended for mobile
application news it started to fetch the
news with thousands of properties and
thousands of items
but the news are actually not the fun
thing what else do we have at our news
it's likes it's comments
and when we look at the comments
comments have authors so we need another
fetch to our user to fetch the author of
these
comments and so on
and that is not because that was a bad
application design or a bad service
application design it was
that rest was
was designed around the concept of
resources so we wanted this isolation
because because it scales nice and we
have these nice buckets like a user
endpoint that deals with everything user
and so on and so forth
so we could optimize that with rest we
could now start and create mobile
endpoints or start with spa spheres or
something like that
but we would
invest a lot of
work and a lot of new api to just solve
now for every new device that we create
on the problems
so when facebook looked at their data
fetching graphs they saw they saw
something like this and we call that a
data waterfall
these are consecutive data fetches where
we first get the user
but
we cannot fetch the next request before
we have the user data because we need an
id that is hidden in that data that we
don't need from the user request and
then we fetch the next thing but we
still have to wait for all the requests
to resolve before we can fetch the very
next thing
so we are kind of blocked and this is
why the facebook application back then
performed so bad
that is where
three guys at microsoft came up with a
new data technology to fetch data or
expose
the domain layer of facebook in a much
better way
so in graphql
this is basically the hello world of
graphql
we could ask
for what we want essentially graphql
reverses the responsibility
of what to fetch and empowers
the consumer of our api
to ask for exactly what he or she needs
so in this case we want to have just the
username
of
our service
and our graphql server would respond
with exactly the requested data
but as our components change our data
needs like we're moving from desktop to
mobile
we have different data fetching needs
and maybe we need some more data maybe
need the profile picture of that user
so we could just
craft a new request for this new use
case and ask for more data
and again
our server would just respond with the
data we asked for
and if we look at that
we realize that graphql is not about
flat data structure
it's about data trees
and that's why
it's so great with graphql to explore
connections
because i can drill into my friends
maybe in the facebook use case
and
not only fetch the user but in the same
instance already all the friends of this
user
i could go even further and fetch in the
same request
also the
news and the comments that i need
and
if we look at that
we can see
that we are repeating things that we
want to fetch me for instance is a user
and friends is a list of users and in
both cases we are fetching name and last
scene
so that's why facebook actually
introduced something we call a fragment
and the fragment
is our primitive of composition in
graphql it allows us to compose fragment
hierarchies as we
compose component
hierarchies in our front end
or class hierarchies in our backends
but more to that later
so graphql
gives clients or consumers the power to
ask for exactly what they want and
nothing more
so what is graphql
graphql is a query language for your api
and a runtime
to fulfill those queries
and that means in graphql we have a
single endpoint
and we can get all the data we need
in a single request
and that means we don't have the problem
of over or under fetching that we have
with traditional data fetching
technologies
over fetching is every time an endpoint
like the user endpoint gives us too much
data gives us data we don't need we
maybe just wanted the username but we
get all the informations about the user
so that we call over fetching
under fetching is the reverse problem
we fetch the news
and there is an author id in there but
we don't want this id we actually want
the name of the author so we under
fetched and have to do a consecutive
data fetch to get the action information
we need
graphql is built on a strong type system
because when facebook looked at their
api they said oh we have a awesome
domain model that we designed in our
internal api
we want to make it expose
or we want to be able to expose it
without compromise
and this type system this strong type
system in graphql
makes it very predictable to use the api
from a consumer perspective
because when graphql tells me to that
a field is a string or a non-nullable
string it will never violate that
contract
on top of that graphql is real time
but enough of the talk let's see some
code
but before we see some code
let me
say one last thing here so in graphql we
have operations and that's an
important aspect to understand we have
three operation kinds we have queries
that is side effect free reads on our
model on the back end and then we have
something called we call a mutation then
our right operations and if you compare
that to rest it's the
post patch delete
that we have to figure out which verb we
actually have to use in rest
and
subscription is our real time capability
to query the system in real time when
something is happening so the events in
our system
in this first demo we will have a look
at queries
so let's dive just in actually let me
get rid of this
and then
go in so this is an
empty
project or it's not even a project it's
just an empty folder
and what we're going to do is create a
graphql server and see what we need to
do to create a graphql server
so the first thing we should do is maybe
just create a web server so net new web
we'll just create an empty web project
it's done at asp.net core
and if we look at that
there's not much to it right we have a
program cs we have a hello world here we
could run that call this endpoint it
will say hello world so these are the
basics so how do we make it a graphql
server so the first thing we need to do
is add a package and we are adding the
hot chocolate
dot asp.net core package here
did i miss
no
should be all right
okay that's adding normal the hot
chocolate graphql server for the net
let's see if everything is in here
okay it's now in
and with that
we can build a graphql server and i said
that operations are important and we are
going to build a query operation
so that means let's create a query dot
cs
and this query.cs is a simple class that
will represent our query type
let me put
just an empty class in here
so in order to
expose something in my graphql server
and let's start with a simple hello
world here we need something that we
call a resolver in graphql
a resolver
is just a simple method
in hot chocolate so i'm just creating
here a method called hello which has a
input like an argument we should we
would say in graphql or a parameter in c
sharp
that is called name and has default of
word
and from that we compose just a string
here that says hello
common name let's run that
so it's building
two seconds
and it's up
let me just copy this url
let's paste it in here
that's not what we want
and that is correct because i forgot
something so we created um a correct
operation type here but we set and
set to our web server nothing how to
deal with that
so in graphql to make the graphql server
we actually go here and look at our web
application builder and then we say
builder.services.add
graphql server
and then
we add our query type as an operation to
it so we say add query type
query
and now we have a graphql server but
there's still one piece missing and that
is the transport at the moment we just
have mapped this get endpoint here and
to make make it a graphql server we need
to say map a graphql
and then we are done
let's rebuild that
and let's see
if it's now a graphql server
i always struggle with the hot reload
no hot
reload
who actually wanted hot reloading on
that
okay
okay and that's what i expect so we get
uh
four or four
because we don't have map this initial
endpoint anymore
and the graph to an endpoint by default
is mapped on the graphql route and if i
go in this route
i am greeted here with bananacachpop
that is the graphql ide that our open
source project has built
and we can now dive into our api by
creating a document here
and says you want to create a new
document for our api i say yes
and then i could start writing my
graphql query here but before i do that
i can dive into my schema and look at
what it exposes and we can see that i'm
exposing here the query type
and down here i can see that the query
type has a hello field
and this hello field has an argument
name
which returns a string and has a default
word
so why am i saying that because graphql
exposes my internal api over the wire
in a much richer way than
i could do with rest it doesn't work
just with those simple cases like if you
have interfaces or things like that it
will also translate to graphql and we
will see that in a minute but let's
start with this simple thing here
we can just now write a graphql query
and ask for the hello field and if we
run that we get hello world
and since we have an argument we can
pass data in like michael
and then i get hello michael
so that is nice let's make it more
complex
let's put some more data structures in
here
for instance let's add an author
typical example i know
and maybe a book and the book has an
author
and then we introduce a new resolver to
our query type
and that is the get books resolver and
the get books resolver will return here
two books of the same author
so let's go back to our graphql point
and refresh our schema
and let's have a look at that schema
we immediately can see that we now have
a books field and it's called books
because in graphql we don't use these
verbs like get
and and things like that so we wouldn't
also we would also remove things like
async things that are dot netty but not
graphically
okay we also can have a look
at it differently like this our query
type we can now dive into our books
field here and then can dive into the
author to fetch the name let's do that
so we fetch above here hello still
but now we also want the books
and from the books maybe just the title
and when we fetch that we exactly get
what we asked for
but we also can fetch like everything
and go in and ask for the author as well
and the author doesn't have a title but
a name
we format that
something is wrong that is not right
okay
and fetch that and then i get what i
asked for
okay
that is awesome let me close that
and let's get to it back to the slides
so let's recap that
that was our query operation type
and the query operation type has
something that we call in graphql
resolver that's the c sharp method here
and
when our graphql server looks at this
class it will translate it into a
graphql type that looks like this
and in a graphql type
this by the way is the annotation based
approach
and
when facebook invented graphql they
started with the annotation-based
approach so essentially you have an api
we infer from that the graphql types put
a thin layer of graphql on the top
and then essentially our domain model is
exposed
so in the graphql type hello is called a
field and the field in graphql is like a
method in.net
and
then we have in our field arguments like
in a proper method we don't have to have
arguments but we can have
and these arguments can have default
values like in.net
but we even can have more here we could
have object trees as
default values that we cannot have in
dotnet
and at the end here you see always this
bang operator because in graphql we have
the reverse
types are
nullable by default
and if we want to make them nullable we
apply the bang operator this is a bit
reversed from the net way like in.net we
put a question mark at the end to market
nullable okay
let me say something about the transport
because in graphql
we write this nice query but how does it
translate over the wire
so the typical graphql request is an
http post request
so um if you go and look for instance at
twitter twitter uses graphql then you
see only http
and then there's graphql graphql works
over http
by the spec graphql is actually
transport agnostic
that is why you also can use websockets
to use graphql grpc or server-side
events works also over these
so let's make it more complex and build
a more complex backend
and we have
let me go through that
we have built a little demo application
with which we teach graphql that is this
crypto application here where you can
check crypto prices the prices are not
real so don't buy
so this application is what i call a
modern application what is a modern
application
and this is a
yeah like
like a fancy term but for me a modern
application is reactive
and
that means if i for instance go into
here the data really lives
that
often translate into me using
observables you can see the prices
changing
but if i go back into my dashboard view
the prices in the ticker will change
when everything whenever something
changes in the back end by the way this
real-time data is graphical over
websockets so this doesn't work over
http or the simple data fetching is done
over http
but let's have a look at the network tab
now it's pretty small but you can see
here two graphql requests because i
navigated essentially to the bitcoin
price let's kill that refresh the app
so
ah that's the internet is really not so
nice here
i struggled yesterday with it but okay
but what you can see is that we have a
single graphql request to get all the
data for our components
and if i go now to the bitcoin price or
to any other price let's go to this one
we have again just one more graphql
request because because we can fetch
everything we need
at any point in time in one request and
that makes it super resilient over
mobile connections like you're on a bus
you have a 3g connection you fetch
something it's not 10 000 connections
that wait for other connections to
finish it's a single connection to fetch
your data
okay
let's have a look at how we could build
such a back end
and let me go back to the slides here
so just recap so a goal for our
modern application that we want to build
is that we want to have a fast iteration
we don't want to block our front-end
engineer of building the front end
meaning
he should not wait for us in the back
end to create a new rest endpoint so
just that he can finish his use case he
should just tell the backend what he
needs or he or she needs
and we want to have strong contracts and
you saw how the net api
easily translates to graphql in
graphical we actually have more type
constructs than in.net
because in graphql we have for instance
unions we don't have that in not net
even
and on top of that modern applications
should enable me in development time
that i'm
really work with static typing and
graphql is statically typed and that
translates to me in react when i compile
my react application i get proper
compilation errors if i ask for the
wrong things
okay
let's go
and have a look at the next demo and
that is
how would i deal with proper data
and
typically a lot of
engineers still love entity framework
so let's have a look at how i could
expose something that is in my entity
framework and in this demo
okay let me click that away
i have just a db context and this db
context provides the base data for the
api we saw so we have an asset
that is essentially my coin here and i
have information about the asset
and i have the asset context which is my
db context here and i have the asset
prices
okay so how could we make that a graphql
server so what we learned
in our first demo is that we need to
create an operation type here so we
could start again with the query type
that we built before
so empty class query
so how do we expose our entity framework
data here
that's quite easy we learned it's just a
method so we could create a method
called assets getassets that returns an
iqueryable from our db context
there's one thing in graphql we want to
parallelize data fetching so we can
fetch data really quickly
and that's why we used a method
dependency injection
meaning we are not creating all the
services that we need for all the
resolvers at once we are looking what
your request looks like and then we only
create the services for the resolvers
you really need
so we are injecting here the asset db
context and then we're just returning
the assets
okay let's set that up in our server we
already have the add graphql server here
to host our query type we just do add
query type
and then query that's what we did before
right let me just reformat that
so what you can see i'm using a pool db
context up there and i'm using a pool db
context because i want a fast server i
don't want to waste memory of a scope db
context so i'm pulling it and that also
allows me to use multiple db context in
parallel
so i need to explain kind of to my
graphql engine how to deal with that so
i can say
register
db context
the asset db context
and
this db context actually is a pooled db
context it's not scoped and now my
graphql engine knows that it has to get
the the db context from the db context
factory
use it and then return it to the pool
i don't deal with this complicated stuff
i just tell my graphql engine about it
okay let's just
dotnet watch and this time
no hard reload
this should be a default
okay let's wait for it to compile
and there it is let's go back to our
browser here
it's now on port 5000 graphql
and let's re-fetch
my graphql schema
let's have a look at the schema
reference and i can see i have a assets
field here and i have all these property
of my assets and i have my asset
pricier so let's query that
so i again start with my graphql query
give me assets maybe let's just fetch
the asset names
and then i fetch that and i get all the
data
but this also introduced kind of a
problem here because it's my whole
database
and if i had more in there that would be
really a problem
and this
is the right time to talk about
pagination because when facebook created
graphql they also
rethought how to do pagination
so typically when we talk about
pagination
you would talk about offset pagination
and that's the skip and take what you do
but facebook with
a lot of
new data that is coming in by users all
the time had a problem with
this skip take approach
because
when you maybe were on page one
and you wanted to skip to page two and
now new data comes in and you go to page
two you again had the same data
because we are not pinned to our items
and it could also happen that you have
the exact same data because it's so much
data came in
that you maybe even went backwards
by going forwards
so they introduced something that they
call cursor-based pagination
and cursor-based pagination pins the
item
with a key
so it takes your id of the entity
and essentially navigates from that id
so in cursor based pagination we would
say
we take five items
after
the id five the item with the id five
and as new data comes in our pages
actually move
so we don't get repeated data
so what do i have to do to do because of
his pagination sounds complex
so
actually
we just say
use
paging that
will recompile was more about the
concept then
and now i can refresh here my graphql
schema and i see okay there's something
wrong schema has changed
because we now have a type that they
call a connection so every list they
essentially say that's a connection to a
different node in my graph
and you can see i have edges edges are
essentially my asset and the cursor to
that asset
and i also have nodes which is kind of a
clean
view at my list and i have paging info
where i have the end cursor of a page
the start cursor or indicator if there's
more data let's try that out a bit
so we could say nodes
and then i just again want the name here
and i fire that
and then i only get 10 items because
that's the default we have configured in
hot chocolate 10 items by default you
can change that default
okay and i also can
kind of look at the paging info i just
want to do a fast forward paging here so
let's just ask for does it has a next
page
and what is the end cursor
and if i ask for that
it will say the
it has a next page and this is the end
cursor and then i can use like the
arguments in my field what my paging
middleware just injected into that field
i want after the cursor
this guy here
i want the first two items
and if i do that i just get the next two
items navigated from the last item in my
list
okay
let's just wipe that out
go back to our
slides
okay and i said use pagination is
actually a field middleware what does a
field middleware mean
so this is my
resolver
and this guy up here is my field
middleware and the field middleware is
the exact same thing that we have in
asp.net core just on the request so in
asp.net core we would say use
authentication use websockets and if we
put them one after the other it builds a
pipeline and that's the same thing that
we do here by putting use paging on the
top we compile from that a
pipeline for this field where use
pagination is actually use paging is
actually the first item in the pipeline
and after that comes the resolver
we have more of these
middlewares like we could say use paging
use projects news filtering new sorting
which add new data
capabilities to your graphql resolver
so a field middleware works like this i
said it's a pipeline the use paging
middleware essentially asks
for the next
pipeline element in the list
of the pipeline
and then get assets will be executed
which returns a variable and then use
paging will apply on this queryable
slicing and if we add all the other
middlewares here then we can see so use
pagination defers to the next filtering
the first to the next sorting the first
to the next then we return the filtering
we create an expression for sorting we
apply that on our variable and so on and
at the end this is translated into sql
in the case of entity framework
this
graphql query translates into
the sql representation
but actually graphql is not
a query language for your database sql
is much better
but this is just the capabilities we can
do with field middlewares actually
graphql is best on top of your
application layer
so if you have a proper domain layer
expose this
paging will work also with this you can
have a custom paging provider for
your domain layer
but let's have a look at the data
middlewares first
okay so i said we can pipeline that here
so we can say use projection
then we can say
use filtering
and then we can say
use sorting so that's our pipeline now
this guy belongs to the graphql core
because it's a core functionality
these guys are integration for database
provider and we
we actually integrate with everything
that is there so if you bring us a
mongodb it works if you go with cosmos
db it works if you go with entity
framework everything under there it
works and we are also working on elastic
as a search provider on top
okay because these are data
middlewares we need to kind of tell our
graphql server that we
want to use projections here and we want
to use filtering
so we centrally tell our graphql engine
that we are now using these data
middlewares
okay should rebuild
no i stopped it that was not good
just a second
thank you
okay let's refresh that
we have a new schema let's have a quick
look at it
if we now look at our arguments of our
field we can see we have the paging
arguments but we also here have now a
where argument on order argument
so i kind of can now say give me all the
assets
and i want the asset name
and i want the price
and from the price i want the latest
price
um but actually
order this stuff please
buy the price
i use the price information and then by
by the market
by the
market cap so the market capitalization
of the coin so i want the
the coin with the highest market
capitalization at the top so we're
ordering it descendingly
let's do that
and i get it exactly like i want so i
can empower the client to ask for the
data and also tell my bank and
how i want this data
and let's have a quick
look
at
oh
no that's a other one this guy here
look at this
it's exactly the the data i asked for
translated to the exact database query
language and it works actually with
even better
than with a native mongod adb driver
okay
so
let's go back to my slides and one
morning here so actually
i wouldn't expose it like that just
expose my database so as i said use your
domain layer use your application layer
and if you expose filtering like that
tell the graphql engine what you want to
expose here so i would limit that i
don't have the time to show you but you
can actually create a little graphql
type and
tell it what filtering is allowed
because we don't want to have maybe
text search filters on our sql database
okay
let's talk about
different kinds of data let's talk about
rest because when you integrate graphql
and that's how it actually started
is that you might have other services
you might have a rest infrastructure or
you might have
a grpc infrastructure with lots of
microservices
so what we talked about was graphql and
the data layer so far but actually
graphql would go on the business layer
that's how facebook intended it
but when they released graphql to the
public it was used more like that
because people had their existing
infrastructures with microservices or
domain services and they would use
graphql to make it easier to work with
their microservice infrastructure so
they would put it on top of that
and that can be in different ways like i
could have a part of that as internal
data structures i could use like the db
context as an internal data and then
merge that with data from other
microservices for instance in our
example here we will have a price change
service that lives in the cloud as an
azure function and pro
provides aggregated
data functionality so like the
percentage change that a coin does in a
specified amount of time
so our rest service has a url like this
you can call it it's actually online
ah you can't because i didn't post a
real url
okay
so our service would return a data
structure like this like when i asked
for the
bitcoin for the monthly change i would
get a percentage change here like
0.1 percent for instance and i want to
integrate that into my graphql service
so how would i do that
let's just wipe out my other demos here
so
we don't get confused
and let's start with demo three
okay that's the same service that we saw
before so i have my sdb context here but
it's a couple of iterations further
so i maybe have now account types like
users and stuff like that and i now want
to
integrate that with data from my rest
endpoint or for my microservices so how
could i do that in the case of rest
so rest is unstructured data okay it
could have a swagger schema or so on but
mine is just unstructured data so
graphql has something that they call the
the data definition language or the
graphql sdl and i can use that
to describe the unstructured data that i
have there so i could say
schema.graphql
and then i could
add
a type here and that was the type i
showed you earlier i could just say
there is an asset price change type in
the cloud and it's a json object and
grab this
field here from that json
and it's actually a float so now i type
this data structure that i have
somewhere there i ignored the fields
that i don't want from it
and then i could integrate that
into my graphql schema and that's very
easy i tell my graphql engine that i
actually want json support
and then i kind of say
add
document from file
and then i take the schema.graphql
okay
and there is one more thing so i now
have a type i maybe have this asset or
not this price node type here
and you can see that it already has a
resolver here
and i'm just adding another resolver
and this resolver
fetches
essentially with an http client just
from this rest service and returns
essentially the json element i know i'm
telling it this is actually the price
change type that i described
so let's see how that performs
no hot reload
let's wait for it
okay let's go back to our schema here
let's refresh that
let's have a look at our schema so we
have here query
i said it's a couple of iterations
further so we have more reservers here
so i can drill into my asset here and i
can drill into my price here
and then
i have my price change type here so i
can ask for the
price change like the time span you can
see there's an enum
to ask for my service and then i get
back this price change field
and let's do that so i have this field
here
and then let's ask for the change of
each currency
over
the months
and then
ask for the price change let's execute
that
the specified argument is not right why
is it not right
because of
and you see so the graphql client here
doesn't even allow me to call that
but wait a minute this seems slow
eight seconds
that's bad
that's a time to talk about data loader
so
facebook actually introduced this tool
data loader for the rest api originally
and
data loader are an integral
tool in the graphql tool chain
so we just integrated a rest endpoint
what happens when we integrate a
resolver that naively so every time
we have this
change method here we will execute it if
we have a list of 10 items we will 10
times go to this
rest service and ask for it
and a data loader doesn't just help with
http requests it actually could also
help with
fetch requests to other databases
so what we would do here is create a new
component we call the data loader put it
in between our resolver and our fetch
request
and what happens here
is when our resolver will ask our data
loader to fetch
for our cryptocurrency the price change
from that rest service
we would
ask the task cache of the data loader
kind of a promise cache
to give us
the a promise for this data
if it doesn't have a promise for this
data in its cache it will create a new
one
and
then we would wait for the data
so when the execution engine has
executed all the resolvers in our
pipeline
it would
batch all the requests to that
background to that endpoint in one go
so for this our rest endpoint actually
needs a batchable endpoint in this case
i created that so i can ask for multiple
symbols at once
and the dataloser improves data fetching
and ensures consistency in one request
so let's have a look at how that looks
so at the moment our resolver actually
looks pretty
complicated if we offload this
complexity to our data loader it
actually looks like this we ask for the
asset price change data loader
which essentially
um
fetches here again the data for
from that endpoint
but then fetches like multiple things at
once
and then just returns a collection of
json objects and our execution engine
will then fulfill for each resolver the
data
so let's see how that performs
it actually is already
i shouldn't have saved
10 minutes
okay let's go back to here
let's
just execute it again
so the first fetch always is slow
because we built up the schema but you
can see now we are at 112 milliseconds
although we fetch a lot of data from our
rest endpoint
that is a concept in
graphql we call a data loader
okay
so let's
we did that
let's talk about one more aspect and
that is real time data
we have 10 minutes let's do it
so when we talk about real-time data we
are calling about streams of real-time
data so instead of having a single
graphql response we have a stream of
graphql responses and that actually
translates very well to async
innumerables in.net
so when we talk about subscriptions we
are talking about events
in event stream
and
we are talking about a response stream
and how that works is when an event is
triggered we will execute a graphql
query and send that down to our
to our consumer
so let me quickly switch over demo
four
okay so this is again the same server
just
the next iteration phase of it
so and here we have the asset types that
we are using and what we want to do is
essentially implement a new event when
the price is changed we want to get a
price query down to our client that is
when you remember our
ui in the beginning where the price
changed that was a subscription
so let's add first our
class here that is an asset subscription
type in this case it's a root type like
query
and we can add resolvers to it but i
said subscription is about a stream
so we first need to create an event
stream and again i said an event stream
actually translates well to an ic i
async
that is an awaitable stream
and this awaitable stream can you can
hook up to anything to any event system
like redis or whatever and yield events
from there so in this instance i have a
price change service that's an internal
service that triggers us an event and
tells us which price has changed and
yields in that case the symbol of the
price that changed
the second component we need
is a resolver and that is the same
resolver than we did for our query so
this resolver is called on price change
here
and it get gets injected an event
message that is the symbol from this
event stream whenever it occurs
and then we use a data loader here this
time for our database to load this data
efficiently
so the one thing we have to do
is tell our resolver that it actually
subscribes
with the
event stream that we have defined up
here so let's put that in
and then
let's just check that i have set up
everything right because i also need to
register
let me just
check if we have done that subscription
type here add subscription
type
and let's run that dotnet watch
no
hot
i should copy paste that
next talk
so it's starting
okay
it's coming up
so you can see it's a lot more happening
here because we have real-time data
actually we are emulating here price
changes so that's why we're updating
constantly the database pushed by a
backend service
let's refresh here our graphql schema it
actually says oh no
okay it's not ready
to be fetched from
i hope it comes up
that is always
not ready okay that doesn't matter i
have prepared for that use case
so
we have a little endpoint here let me
just get that
workshop is it this one
import badge
let me check no that's a local one
yeah this one
so let's just say api
and go
no
hcc
one second
that would be a shame
it's always subscriptions
workshop no that's the other one
one second let me copy that
it went so well and now it's dying
oh yes sorry
it's api
crypto
crypto crypto
dash
workshop
dot chili cream
dot com slash graphql
okay so here we are
so this is the same service um that i
wanted to have in the end uh we don't
have time to figure out why it's broken
um but essentially what we have there
is now a third type the subscription
type and then we have the on price
change event here
and it's the same data structure that we
actually have in our query so what i can
do now is here subscribe call write a
subscription query and what is awesome
for the consumer of this api
that the only thing he or she has to
change is writing here subscription and
then we can drill the same way into our
data
like we did before
just come on
so we can say on price change that is
our event here and then we can drill
into this like latest price or maybe we
want something from the asset and from
the asset maybe we want the name let me
just reformat that
and then
we can just execute that
and nothing happens and that is because
we subscribed
and there will only something happen
when the back end has some events and i
hope this back end has some events at
any point there they're coming in so
every time when the price changes in the
back end it will execute our query and
send us these responses
you can see it's sometimes pausing
because not always are these
cryptocurrencies changing
and that means sometimes i get a bunch
of events and sometimes nothing
so and let me just
conclude that here
um and that's also what you have to
think about when implementing
subscription you have to think about
throttling maybe you don't want to send
the
the client too many events
otherwise you're frying the mobile
device or
the desktop
um so we have to think about uh
throttling also about quality of service
meaning is this event
like important maybe we need a replay
functionality we can do that in a in our
async stream like fetch the missed
events from the database and first year
them and then start real time
multiplexing is actually solved by the
graphql
ws protocol but still you have to think
about these things
okay
unfortunately like we don't have time
for this so let me jump to
my conclusion
so graphql is evolving rapidly
over the last 10 years think about it 10
years ago facebook started with graphql
and when they open sourced it in 2015
they talked about it they said okay we
have something cool and we are running
it in production for the last four years
at the scale of 500 million users that
do a ton of requests i think it was 20
billion a day so i don't i'm not sure
anymore but graphql is tested in ma as
massive scale it's not a
thing that nobody uses like if you think
about the users of graphql we have
github we have microsoft microsoft teams
runs on graphql microsoft office runs on
graphql
then we have
twitter netflix all graphql
so graphql is running the internet
companies of the current age
with that
i'm done this is all open source you can
go to our github repository if you like
it please give us a star if not
doesn't matter
if you want to follow me
you can
copy the page and
get into contact with us and with that
i'm done
[Applause]
you